going everyone uh welcome back so i want
to make this uh
video because i uh in our community was
talking yesterday about the math behind
how to know
how many sessions you should have uh as
you're reopening to make sure that you
are profitable
[Music]
one of the big issues that's going to
come up is a lot of different states
have different recommendations some of
them are based on percentage of capacity
uh you know reopening through kovit some
of them are
uh you know limited to 10 people or it's
the greater of the two or the lesser of
the two excuse me
um and so what that does is it it
creates a lot of issues
for most gyms because
the profit model is not built for large
group training to not be able to do
large group training
all right and so what i mean by that is
if you're charging let's say
five dollars a session or ten dollars a
session for
what it would work out to in terms of
the attendance for your hundred dollar a
month clients if you're only able to
have ten people per session
at your facility that would include you
and probably one other person so now
you're down to eight
now if you're providing one on eight
service it doesn't make
monetary sense for you
to to be in business right so even
though you get permission to open back
up
it doesn't mean that you're necessarily
gonna have the profit to be able to do
so
so if you were to come back to your full
client schedule uh
when you come back you probably won't be
profitable and so this is how you reopen
the right way
okay so there's two main components to
this and i'll go through each one
as in depth as i can all right the first
is what i was
mentioning just now if you're only able
to
have 10 people per session then you need
to price your services
at the price that that service would be
normally offered
so if people are normally paying 129 a
month at your facility or 150 a month or
whatever
for unlimited and you're only able to
have
60 people a day at your gym if you had
six sessions a day for example
those sessions you can't even have 60
because you're going to be included in
that so now you're talking
you know 50 people a day that you can
service which means you can only service
50 customers all right
so if you're having a one on eight
scenario then you need to charge 300 or
400
a month for that service as long as that
happens
now here's the good news the people who
will want to come back
are going to be itching to come back not
everyone is going to come back but the
people who do want to come back
desperately want to come back
and so they'll likely you'll have the
supply demand curve in your favor
meaning there's more people who want you
then there is availability of time for
you to be able to train
clients all right and so when you have
supply and demand in your favor then it
means you can increase your price
right and so those things work together
for kind of scenario one okay
if you are limited and can't do like
that many people per session etc
okay you need to adjust your price to
reflect the level of service being
provided
not just letting people back into their
old price because it doesn't make
monetary sense
okay now what i'm going to do is talk
about the second piece which is
how do i know when it makes monetary
sense so one of the things in the joomla
secrets book
in section 2 which is the profit levers
which i would highly encourage you
to read before you reopen because it'll
allow you to fix everything that you did
wrong in your gym this is one of the
biggest opportunities of all time
for people who own a gym because right
now society is giving you permission to
change
all these things in your gym at once and
then restart
the right way with the right price
points the right hours the right
amount of people per session all of
those things done right
so that you can maximize the profit and
capacity of facility all right so this
is like
never before will you be able to get
this opportunity so take it
please take 35 minutes and read section
2 of the gym on secrets book
it's free plus shipping go read it all
right now
here's the here's one of the biggest
pieces that i have to provide for you
okay
you want to make sure that you're making
an 80 gross margin minimum on your
services all right this is this has been
a rule of thumb that we've used at gym
launch forever
if you are running on that then you will
be able to make a profit and have a good
business if you do not
and you're like well we're at 75 i'm
telling you every percentage point makes
an enormous difference
so let me give you an example if the
average gym is running on 12.5 margins
per year
all right that's the average gem if you
go from 75 to 83
margins then you added eight percent
to your bottom line so if you went from
12 to 20 that would be a very big deal
right it'd be almost twice as much money
so these percentage points matter all
right
so for us now mind you you can set the
number whatever you want
my rule of thumb is minimum 80. if you
want to be at 85 or 90
by all means go for it all right you
could it's your business you can set it
up the right way
but let me walk through a simple math
example to explain to you exactly how
many sessions you can know by math
that you can reopen at any given moment
okay so
if you have let's say 150 customers
before this and then you reach out to
all of them and only 100 want to come
back
cool so let's say those hundred who have
said yes i want to come back you can
build my card now
all right are billing at 100 a month i
don't recommend that price point but i'm
saying if that is what they're
saying then that's what we're going to
work off of for the for the money math
all right
so that's ten thousand dollars a month
of recurring revenue that you have
built in now if you're running an 80
gross margin that means that on the cost
of delivering the services that doesn't
include rent that doesn't include admin
it doesn't include marketing
just your hard cost of fulfilling a
session all right
is 20 or less of what you are paying
or what you are making okay so what that
means is
if you're making ten thousand dollars a
month for your services
then it should cost you two thousand
dollars a month
or less to fulfill those services so
if we know that we only have two
thousand dollars that's earmarked for
payroll
for fulfillment of those services and
you know it costs you twenty dollars per
session
then it means you have a hundred
sessions that you are able to fulfill on
per month now if we're gonna be smart
about this then we're gonna divide our
100 sessions
by 4.3 which is how many weeks there are
per month on average
which means we have 23 sessions per week
that you're going to be able to fulfill
all right given
the number of people and the amount of
revenue that's being brought in that is
already
happening all right don't go off of
promises i'm begging you go off of
reality
all right you're gonna have like some
people's cars won't go through because
things have changed over the last two
months
some people say they're gonna come back
and then don't some people are like
actually gotta wait for my kids
blah blah blah all right go only off of
reality go off of
what goes through so you get everyone in
you start their billing and then you see
what happens and then you dictate the
schedule right
if you can do that if you can't then
you're gonna have to
down downgrade your estimation by how
much you were making before
with all the cancellations included and
then drop another 10 just in case
and then use that as the number to base
this off of so
10 000 2 000 for payroll that means
if we're getting twenty dollars a
session that's a hundred sessions we
divide that that's per month
by uh the number of weeks in a month
which is uh 4.3 so we have 23 sessions
per week okay and so you can allocate
those let's say that we've got five days
a week monday through friday that might
be normal hours
all right so on those days let's say we
did four sessions a day two in the
morning two in the afternoon so now we
got
twenty we got three left over and so we
can go three on saturday
right in the morning if that's what we
wanted to do right
and so just like that you can get your
payroll you can get your business to a
point where you have an 80
gross margin or higher right and so like
i said that is the minimum
but that is the way that you can know in
your gut that you're opening up in a
position to be profitable
now if you've done the math and you're
like you know what i can only have ten
thousand dollars a month recurring and
my rent is six
well then you're probably not going to
start out profitable
anyways and so at that point you're
gonna have to make harder decisions of
like do i wanna
uh do you wanna do a big pre-sale and
then get another you know 50 or 100
people pre-sold on a trial to
to be able to monetize this um and
that's where cash is really important
right
but big picture most of you don't have
that situation
um and if you did have that kind of rent
then hopefully your revenue is higher
than that hopefully your price is higher
than that etc
um but that's how you that's how you can
figure this out and most people
do this wrong most people are like i'm
trying to open up as many available
times right
or the worst scenario you can have is
and this is what i feel like it's going
to happen for a ton of people is
i'm going to be limited to 10 people per
session i've got 100 clients
i'm going to increase my overhead so
that i can have 10 sessions a day
so i can see all my clients and there
goes your margin
forever and then how do you transition
back and having to cut
sessions right it's not a good way to do
it start as little as you can
start with two sessions a start with 90
margins
right that's fine it's okay start with
90 margins work at two sessions a day
and work your way back start at three
sessions a day whatever right
and so from there um this is one of
those beautiful opportunities that if
you ever had that session that never
really had good attendance
right cut it right cut it get your
margin back
right and uh like i just want everyone
like think kobe
like sure there are things that you
probably wish didn't happen okay
but but take what you can right right
now you can click reset on your business
these are the five things that you need
to do right now all right i'm going to
give you the the cliff notes on what you
need to do
one you need to switch from unlimited to
two or three times a week as your main
offer
all right because right away that will
double or triple your capacity two you
need to switch your billing to a weekly
cadence now it doesn't have to actually
be weekly but it has to be on a weekly
bi-weekly or four-time
or every four week cadence why because
if you do it on every 28 days
you're going to get 13 billions a year
instead of 12 which means you get an
extra
almost eight percent in top line revenue
for the same amount of service
right what that means is if you have 12
margin you get another eight percent
now you're at 20. right almost doubles
how much you make just from that one
change
all right each of these levers is like
that okay so
unlimited to two to three times a week
you're going to switch to
a billing a cadence of weekly bi-weekly
or 28-day cycles
you're going to change your pricing to
match your service
all right which means when you make
these adjustments typically
when you limit people's sessions fewer
people show up which then means that
number of people per session goes down
which means your value goes up
and so that means that you can build
more believe it or not
because people change it changes the
value proposition to the end user so
just remember that
you're not cutting sessions you're
adding value by making it more
personalized because
the sessions are going to be smaller and
more controlled okay and so when you do
that
my minimum recommendation is 167. all
right that's my minimum bare minimum
bear bear bear bear bare minimum which
works out to 39
a week all right bare minimum most
people will be at 49 a week or 59 a week
or 69 a week
okay and that's what you can do for
those uh and that's what the overall
pricing would be so if you did it at
forty nine dollars a week uh it'd be
49.99 don't forget your 99 cents
all right which means you're gonna be
199.99 every 28 days
all right beyond that if you typically
have uh exercise is that you use that
you wanted to get rid of because they
take too much space up and they eat too
much square footage
this is the time to get rid of those
things and take them out of the
programming
in terms of your sessions instead of
being 60 minutes
cut them to 45 all right it'll also
increase your capacity
and decrease your payroll so all of
these things are things that you can do
right now doing it the right way
starting with the right price
with the right services the right amount
of sessions the right margin
so that you can actually come out of
this profitable or even more profitable
than
you did before every person who goes in
and tries to increase the amount of
sessions they're doing
keep the pricing the same and then have
more individualized service
that they're going to do is going to go
out right the math doesn't support it
and so just like if i can give you one
thing just trust the math
all right you will be able to make a
profit be able to provide more value
your customers and actually get
through this so you can grow your gym
which hopefully is your goal
so um that's uh that's that's part one
of how to reopen the right way is
structure everything properly
um i'll probably make another video on
how to how to market and sell before
that but
right now make sure to get this stuff
right if you get the book there's a
letter inside the book on how to
communicate the changes
um you can literally copy it go for it
um it's my gift to you
but yeah if you don't know where the
book is just go to alex'sbook.com
there's a free book there i think it's
on amazon too if you do by the way
leave a review lots of love um anyways
happy wednesday wanted to make sure i
got that out for you and uh keep being
awesome
[Music]
you